what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
are going to be telling you everything
we know so far about seven deadly sins
season two here on this channel we want
to be your number one source for all the
latest news and analysis about the big
release is coming out in 2017 including
Code Geass season 3 attack on Titan
season 2 and seven deadly sins season 2
if you want to be the first to know as
soon as we get some news be sure to
subscribe and make sure you click that
notification bell and if you want to be
in touch with us on a daily basis you
can join our discord server link in the
description I want to give a quick thank
you to my boy Briggs from old day anime
for helping me out with this video he's
already made a bunch of great seven
deadly sins video on his channel so be
sure to check it out the link is in the
description now the release date for
seven deadly sins season 2 was initially
announced for sometime in 2016 but of
course we know that didn't happen a 1
Pictures had published the news that the
series will be coming back with a second
season soon after the OVA
signs of a holy war is aired however
season 2 was then postponed until
sometime in 2017 after signs of a holy
war aired in August and September of
2016 with major changes made in the
staff and cast members now as fans of
course you want season 2 to come out as
soon as possible but these unexpected
changes that were made to the casting
and production team for the OVA signal
to me that potentially there is some
problems within the production team
which unfortunately means that we could
be seeing further complications and
further delays Gaiman guide had reported
back in December that Netflix will be
releasing season two of seven deadly
sins in January of 2017 but that doesn't
seem to be happening either Gaiman guide
also reported the reason why Netflix
took an entire year to work on the seven
deadly sins season two was due to
artistic differences between illustrator
knockabout Suzuki and Netflix bosses now
even though these creative different
issues have allegedly been resolved
these kind of rumors really make me
worried that there is something going on
within the production team and that we
could be looking at further delays as of
January 2017 the official seven deadly
sins Japanese website only has news
about the blu-ray release for the OVA
signs of holy war
which will be coming out on July 16 2017
there are no news about any release date
for season two so as far as the release
date for season two is concerned all
they've told us so far is sometime in
2017 keeping all of that in mind we are
now going to move on to speculating what
is going to happen in season two in
terms of plot and just a quick warning
the rest of this video will contain
spoilers from seven deadly sins season 1
and from the OVA s but we will not
include any manga spoilers in the final
epic showdown of the seven deadly sin
season 1 finale we saw Hendrickson
inject himself with the blood of demons
in order to gain demon power and become
a type of demon himself we also realized
that Hendrickson is specifically
targeting Elisabet for some reason and
we soon learned that this is because
Elizabeth has a strange healing power
hidden inside her and this power finally
manifests itself fully as she is
revealed to be a druid priestess and a
disciple of the goddesses we learned
that Hendrickson actually means
Elizabeth's blood in order to resurrect
the demon clan which had been banished
by the other clans more than 3,000 years
ago near the end of the final episode of
season 1 we also learned on Merlin has
been searching for the location of the
coffin of eternal darkness which is the
place where the demon clan was sealed
away all those years ago
Merlin also mentions that right after
Henriksen was defeated a strange
bird-like creature was seen flying away
towards the southern skies
Merlin then says that she will be
rejoining the seven deadly sins for now
and we see the development of a whole
bunch of romances and shipping this
includes Elizabeth ex malleolus King X
Diane Gauss ER ex Jia ban ex Jericho
guilts under ex Margaret and of course
Merlyn X Anna Mac at the end of the
first season we see Elizabeth along with
the seven deadly sins setting up for a
brand new adventure this time to King
Arthur's Kingdom of Camelot although
bond and King set off on their own for a
while at this point we still don't know
what exactly happened ten years ago and
how exactly the seven deadly sins were
framed
in the epilogue after the final credits
we see gills under green Maura and
Hauser researching ancient symbols and
they noticed that both Meili oldest and
Henrickson had this particular symbol
appear on their face since we know that
Hendrickson had injected himself with
demon blood before the symbol appeared
this proves that melio does also has
demon blood and it's somehow connected
to the banished demon clan now that we
talked about the conclusion to season 1
we are going to talk about the OVA
so be warned OVA spoilers will follow
the two original OVA ZAR pretty simple
one of them is basically filler and the
other one tells the backstory of bond
and how we first met Elaine and drank
from the fountain of you the other thing
that we have to talk about though is the
four episode signs of the holy war OVA
which aired in August and September of
2016
episode 1 of the OVA is mostly
lighthearted but we do learn some
important information near the end
for example we learned that bond wants
to destroy the remains of the great
demon but Merlin stops him because she
considers the demon to be an important
research specimen also at the very end
of the episode we see Mellie Otis
visiting the horn of fair Neuros which
is located the needs to kingdom of
Leona's and which allows people to
communicate with the realm of the
goddess clan this is the same object
that bond encountered in episode 21 when
the goddess told him that she would
bring Elaine back to life if he killed
Mellie Otis at this point it is revealed
that Mellie Otis is actually over 3,000
years old and that he is indeed
connected to the demon clan which fought
against the other clans in the holy war
melio does confronts the goddess for
lying to his friend bond about bringing
Elaine back from the dead but the
goddess taunts him by saying that no
matter what he does those he loves and
cares about will all abandon him once
they learn about his sin man Yoda then
goes on to destroy the horn but of
course this makes us wonder what's in
the melee Olas commit and how could it
be so great that no matter what he does
the people that love will all abandon
him once they learn what he did this I'm
sure will be a big plot point in season
2 and I'm looking forward to finding out
what this sin was after the closing
credits we learned even more a small boy
spots the same bird-like creature that
was first seen flying away in the
final episode of season 1 immediately
after Hendrickson's defeat and at this
point we learned that this creature is
actually a flying arm
most probably Hendrickson's arm we then
see Dreyfus reappear again to ask this
boy about the flying arm that he just
saw proving yet again then in the seven
deadly sins no one really freakin dies
not too much happens in episode 2 of
signs of the holy war except King Bartra
has a mysterious vision and King
demonstrates his amazing dancing fairy
fighting technique 10 out of 10 in
episode 3 the flying armed finally
reaches its destination and what do you
know it is the body of Hendrickson who
is still freakin alive even though he is
badly injured at this point Dreyfus
arrives and gives Henriksen some of his
own blood in order to heal him and they
have a very they were born to make
history type of moment until it is
revealed that Dreyfus now also has the
mark of the demon clan on his face
implying that he himself is now a demon
or that he is being possessed by one in
Episode four we learned that the red
demon and the great demon are actually
among the weakest of the demon clan and
that the strongest demons are known as
the ten commandments and they serve
directly under the demon king we also
learned that King Boris mysterious
vision was of 10 Dark Shadows rising
from the southern kingdom of Camelot and
of course 10 shadow seems to allude to
the Ten Commandment we then see
Hendrickson seemingly opening the seal
that had been keeping the demon clan
locked inside the coffin of eternal
darkness implying that in season two we
are going to witness the seven deadly
sins fighting against the ten
commandments and other powerful demons
in Camelot and that is everything we
know so far about seven deadly sins
season two both in terms of the
production and in terms of the plot here
on this channel we're going to continue
to keep a close eye on any news coming
on about seven deadly sin season 2 so if
you want to be the first to know be sure
to subscribe and be sure to click that
notification valve if you want to chat
with us on a daily basis you can join
our discord server the link is in the
description and I want to give a big
thank you to my man Brig
from all day anime for helping me out
with this video Riggs has already made a
whole bunch of great videos on the seven
deadly sins so I'm going to link his
seven deadly sins playlist right here be
sure to check it out
thank you so much for watching guys
thanks for all your support and until
next time see ya space Cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]